the deal is done Elon Musk says he's now
the chief twit of the social media giant
e Waltz as you see into tutors San
Francisco headquarters brandishing a
bathroom sink let that sink in he joked
and reality has sunk in for the woke
employees of the company musk also
saying though that it is important for
the future of civilization to have a
common digital Town Square and he's
promising advertisers that Twitter will
not become a free-for-all hellscape but
that reassurance may be fully on deaf
ears in the last 90 days at least 530
employees have called it quits at
Twitter and those who stayed are
demanding quit leadership does not
discriminate against workers on the
basis of their race gender disability
sexual orientation or political beliefs
critics quick to point out that some of
those same employees apparently use
political beliefs to discriminate
against conservatives yep so uh do you
like musk yeah I do like musk I like
them and what do you think is going to
be different on Twitter well obviously
he's not gonna he's not going to
suppress conservative voices I mean he's
going to make it uh he says what does he
say it's not going to be a free-for-all
hellscape but he's going to make it the
Public Town Square are you on Twitter
yeah he also
um said that he wants to take it public
in a few years which means that he wants
to make it a money you know he's got to
make it successful and you know those
people who quit I mean they've got to be
people who know that you know they're
responsible for you know making sure
that certain opinions have been squashed
and also
um I think you should clean house
totally I think he's totally right clean
house go in there I like the sink
analogy I think it's great when you pay
44 billion dollars for a website
basically you better have your say well
he overpaid and he knows it he did
overpay and he'll have his say and and
it's a bloated company the head count is
bloated and so he'll have to cut some
staff and that's fine they're not making
any money Geraldo and liberals didn't
care they were like well let's just hire
a hundred thousand workers not make any
money what's the problem well the
problem is you're losing money and
you're corrupting the country so he'll
come in and you have a red wave you you
have Hunter Biden investigations going
after the Red Wave and you have musk
running Twitter this is the Democrats
worst nightmare well I don't know when
you pay 44 billion though Dana you
should have your right to innovate and
he is an innovator yeah and so far so
good with Tesla 530 is a great start
530 quitting yeah
that's what I meant to ask you what
about Trump inviting Trump back I think
he I think musk had said that if he were
to take over he will do it so um we can
wait and see if I was an employee there
I would just one I'd be curious like
okay well does he have a way to make it
better I mean they love him for the
environmental Vehicles they love him for
the fact of starlink and the fact that
he's providing internet access to the
people of Ukraine while they're being
pounded by Russia they like a lot of
things that he's done like maybe just
give him a second
I think that's great advice give him a
second but what about the fact that he
has become a real force in terms of
commenting on Ukraine with using
starlink as a leverage uh commented on
Taiwan uh and uh China should have some
influence there he says he says some
bombshell things uh that uh you know
maybe we should worry a little bit or
should we about checks and balances I
don't know I I think right now I just
have to I have to apologize
um that that uh poem red wheelbarrow was
by William Carlos Williams and not E.E
Cummings this would be my last show
I love how the Twitter staff is worried
that there's going to be new
discrimination against political beliefs
no the word that they can no longer
discriminate against political uh
beliefs by the way a free-for-all
hellscape sounds kind of fun Dana you
know what I'm saying permission to use
an analogy okay and it was one that you
used the other day the Mrs Doubtfire
analogy Twitter is Mrs Doubtfire and the
algorithm is Robin Williams and musk's
knows what's under the hood and he's
going to end up showing Twitter what
they've been missing what Mrs Doubtfire
really is and that's going to explode a
lot of heads because these are people
that only see certain news perspectives
based on an algorithm he knows what the
algorithm is he's gonna go like this hat
and he's gonna throw it out there and
it's gonna be missing and he's not an
engineer he's not a scientist he majored
in I think philosophy and economics I'm
not sure but he mastered the electric
battery he mastered space exploration
this is going to be a no-brainer for him
and he's not doing it because he has to
right he doesn't he's not even doing it
because he really wants to he just
decided to do it because he because he
realized this Twitter has really been
screwing up this country yeah he knows
it he's been quoting EE Cummings yes I
trust
musk as much as I trust the New York
Times editorial board I think that
they're equally credible
or
not